AGREEMENT, ON WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR ROSEANNE
BARR'S CAREER-ENDING TWEETS.
WATCH.
>> WE HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO
WAS ELECTED AFTER
TRAFFICKING IN BARELY,
BARELY CLOAKED RACIAL
ANIMUS.
A LOT OF OTHER PEOPLE IN
MANY WAYS MIMICS THIS KIND
OF LANGUAGE.
>> THIS KIND OF STUFF IS A
DIRECT BY PRODUCT OF HOW
DONALD TRUMP BEHAVES AND
THINGS HE HAS SAID.
>> TO THAT POINT.
>> THINGS HE DOES NOT
CONDEMN.
>> WE HAVE TO STOP
PRETENDING THAT THIS
PRESIDENT HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH IT.
THAT HE IS NOT EMBOLDENING
RACISTS AND RACISM AND
GIVING THEM A PLATFORM AND
MAKING IT OKAY.
>> Tucker: RICHARD GOOD
STEIN LAWYERS WHO ADVISED
BOTH OF HILLARY CLINTON'S
CAMPAIGNS JOINS US TONIGHT.
RICHARD, I DON'T BEGRUDGE
ANY POLITICAL PARTY OR ITS
SURROGATES IN THE MEDIA AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GRAB AN
ADVANTAGE WHEN YOU SEE ONE.
ON THE SUBJECT OF TWEETS,
WHICH NO NORMAL PERSON WOULD
DEFEND.
THEY'RE AWFUL.
WHY THE IMPULSE TO
IMMEDIATELY MAKE IT A
PARTISAN POLITICAL ISSUE
WHEN THERE IS A HUMAN
MESSAGE IN THIS CONVERSATION
WHICH IS DON'T ATTACK PEOPLE
ON THE BASIS OF THEIR RACE.
LIKE IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
WHY THE IMPULSE TO MAKE IT
PARTISAN?
>> CERTAINLY WHAT ROSEANNE
BARR DID WAS PATHETIC NOT
JUST TO SAY IT BUT TO BLAME
IT ON AMBIEN.
SHE ALSO SAID IT WAS
MEMORIAL DAY.
IT WAS -- AND THIS IS
SOMEBODY WHO HAD SAID THE
EXACT SAME THING ABOUT SUSAN
RICE.
WHO HAD BASICALLY DEFENDED
THE WHOLE --
>> Tucker: YOU DON'T NEED TO
CONVINCE ME THE TWEET WAS
BAD.
I'M THERE ALREADY.
>> ACTUALLY THERE ARE PEOPLE
I SUSPECT WHO ACTUALLY ARE
KIND OF JOINING TO HER
DEFENSE.
RIGHT?
OH, THIS IS SOMEHOW HER
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS ARE
BEING INFRINGED.
NONSENSE.
>> Tucker: WHAT I'M SAYING,
LOOK, FOR MOST OF MY ADULT
LIFE THE SENIOR DEMOCRAT IN
THE UNITED STATES SENATE WAS
A FORMER CLAN RECRUITER.
OKAY?
ROBERT BYRD.
A LOT OF THINGS NAMED AFTER
I'M NOT EVEN ATTACKING
ROBERT BYRD.
HE APOLOGIZED.
BUT LET'S GET A LITTLE
PROPORTION HERE.
THE OUTRAGE IS SELECTIVE.
I'M NOT DEFENDING THE
ROSEANNE CRAP, BUT I ALSO
THINK WHEN PEOPLE ARE
JUMPING UP AND DOWN ACTUALLY
TRUMP DID THIS, IT'S PURELY
POLITICAL.
LET'S BE HONEST.
>> ACTUALLY I THINK THAT
PEOPLE WHO DON'T SUBSCRIBE
TO YOUR VIEW BELIEVE THE
FOLLOWING.
DONALD TRUMP HAS GIVEN
LICENSE TO PEOPLE BY SAYING
THEY ARE GOOD NAZIS BY
MOCKING HANDICAP PEOPLE.
BY BASICALLY, YOU KNOW.
>> Tucker: MOCKING HANDY CAP
PEOPLE.
>> REMEMBER HE WENT LIKE
THIS BY "NEW YORK TIMES"
REPORTER.
>> Tucker: WAS HE MOCKING
ALL HANDICAPPED PEOPLE.
>> IT WAS THAT GUY.
IT WAS PATHETIC.
THE LIST IS ON AND ON.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS
THOUGH, WHEN DONALD TRUMP
DOES THAT AND PEOPLE SAY
WELL, HE WON, SO HIS STAFF
CAN GO WELL I CAN MIMIC
PEOPLE AND MAKE FUN OF JOHN
MCCAIN WHO IS DYING.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
THEN PEOPLE WHO ARE
SUPPORTERS THINK AT HIS
RALLIES PEOPLE WHO COVER HIS
RALLIES SAY THESE PEOPLE
WERE LOVELY AND THEN THE
RALLY WOULD START AND THEY
WOULD SAY THE MOST
ANTI-SEMITIC.
>> Tucker: I HAVE BEEN ON
TELEVISION FOR 1020 YEARS
THE NASTINESS OF HATE MAIL I
RECEIVE REMAINS CONSTANT.
I DIDN'T BLAME OBAMA FOR THE
HATE MAIL AND DEATH THREATS
I GOT.
I DIDN'T BLAME OBAMA.
THIS IS A LARGER QUESTION.
PART OF THE QUESTION IS, DO
PEOPLE WHO ARE ENGAGING IN
RACISM, LIKE AL SHARPTON,
HAVE THE RIGHT TO LECTURE
THE REST OF US ABOUT RACISM?
DO THEY?
IS AL SHARPTON THE SPOKESMAN
YOU WANT AGAINST RACISM,
REALLY?
>> NO, HE IS NOT.
I AGREE WITH YOU.
BUT I DO THINK IT IS
UNDENIABLE THAT THE FACT
THAT DONALD TRUMP SPEWS WHAT
HE DID ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL
AND AS PRESIDENT TO TALK
ABOUT GOOD NAZIS IS
SOMETHING THAT SENDS A
SIGNAL LIKE I BASICALLY AM
DRAWING SUCKER FROM THESE
PEOPLE.
AND IT'S WHY HE TWEETS ABOUT
EVERY STUPID THING UNDER THE
SUN.
NFL PLAYERS KNEELING.
CAN'T --
>> Tucker: DRAW ME IN
DEFENDING EVERY DUMB TRUMP
TWEET WHICH I'M NOT.
WE ARE AGAINST RACISM, I
HOPE.
I CERTAINLY AM.
WE DO A LOT OF SHOWS ON IT.
>> OF COURSE.
>> Tucker: IS IT WRONG TO
DISIM NATE AGAINST
DISCM NATE AGAINST
DISCRINATE AGAINST
DISCRIMITE AGAINST
DISCRIMINA AGAINST
DISCRIMINATEGAINST
DISCRIMINATE AINST
DISCRIMINATE AGAST
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST PEOPLE
ON SKIN COLOR.
>> THAT'S GIVEN THAT'S
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION.
>> NO I'M TALKING ABOUT
RACISM.
IS IT WRONG TO DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST PEOPLE BASED ON SKIN
COLOR?
IF IT'S NOT, THEN WHY DO WE
CARE ABOUT ROSEANNE SAID.
IF THERE IS.
YOU SHOULDN'T BASE PEOPLE ON
THE BASIS OF
CHARACTERISTICS, DO YOU
AGREE WITH THAT.
>> I THINK ROSEANNE BARR AND
PEOPLE LIKE HER TO HO TALK
ABOUT BLACK PEOPLE AS APES
IS WRONG.
>> Tucker: I AGREE.
IT'S DISGUSTING.
IS IT WRONG TO DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST SOMEONE ON THE BASIS
OF A SKIN COLOR, TO HOLD
THEM BACK ON THE BASIS OF
THEIR SKIN.
IT'S A REALLY SIMPLE ANSWER.
CAN YOU ANSWER IT.
>> OF COURSE, BUT, YOU ARE
ACTING LIKE SOMEHOW SLAVERY
DIDN'T HAPPEN.
>> Tucker: I DIDN'T SAY
THAT.
>> THAT'S THE INTIMATION YOU
ARE GETTING AT.
>> Tucker: PLEASE.
>> THAT'S WHAT YOU ARE
GETTING AT.
>> Tucker: THAT'S NOT WHAT
I'M GETTING AT.
I AM A STRAIGHTFORWARD
PERSON.
DON'T ATTACK ME.
I'M ASKING YOU ABOUT A
PRINCIPLE.
WHICH IS IT WRONG TO HURT
PEOPLE, TO HOLD THEM BACK,
DENY THEM THINGS THEY WOULD
OTHERWISE GET BECAUSE OF
THEIR RACE?
IT'S A REALLY SIMPLE
QUESTION YES OR NO.
>> I AGREE THAT PEOPLE
SHOULD NOT BE DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST.
>> Tucker: NO.
PLEASE ANSWER THE QUESTION.
>> THEY SHOULD NOT BE
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST THEIR
FACE.
BUT WE DON'T HAVE A
COLORBLIND SOCIETY.
ERIC HOLDER AND OTHER BLACK
CABINET OFFICIALS HAVE
TROUBLE HAILING A TAXICAB.
>> Tucker: BY THE WAY, I'M
NOT DENYING THAT.
I'M MERELY SAYING IS IT
WRONG TO PRACTICE RACISM
AGAINST PEOPLE?
>> OF COURSE.
>> Tucker: IT.
>> YES.
>> Tucker: YOU WOULD SAY
IT'S TOTALLY WRONG TO SAY TO
A CHILD BECAUSE OF YOUR SKIN
COLOR WE'RE HOLDING YOU
BACK?
THERE IS A MASSIVE LAWSUIT
AGAINST HARVARD RIGHT NOW BY
ASIAN STUDENTS WHO ARE
BASICALLY PROVEN THAT
HARVARD DIDN'T LET THEM IN
BECAUSE OF THEIR RACE.
>> RIGHT.
>> Tucker: IS THAT OKAY WITH
YOU.
>> JEWS USED TO BE SUBJECTED
TO THE EXACT SAME THING.
>> Tucker: WITH T. WAS
WRONG.
LIBERALS SUPPORT IT NOW.
>> RIGHT.
>> Tucker: THOSE PEOPLE
LECTURE ME ABOUT RACISM.
>> VIRTUE IN DIVERSITY.
>> Tucker: VIRTUE NEW
DISCRIMINATION?
>> CALL IT WHAT YOU WANT
TUCK TONGUE I'M CALLING IT
WHAT IT IS.
WE BOTH AGREED THAT
PENALIZING PEOPLE ON THE
BASIS OF THEIR RACE IS
IMMORAL YOU AGREED WITH THAT
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW FULL
SUPPORT OF LIBERALS SAME
ONES LECTURING US ABOUT
RACISM IT'S TOO MUCH.
>> I'M SAYING THERE IS A
QUILT INVOLVED AND, YES,
DISCRIMINATING AGAINST
PEOPLE ON THE BASIS OF THEIR
SKIN COLOR IS WRONG.
BUT PEOPLE WERE HELD BACK
FOR HUNDREDS OF YEARS.
>> Tucker: I AGREE.
>> TO BASICALLY ACT LIKE
THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
>> Tucker: I'M NOT ACTING
LIKE IT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
I THINK IT'S THE CENTRAL SIN
OF AMERICA.
I HAVE THINK IT'S OUR
ORIGINAL SIN.
I THINK IT'S TERRIBLE.
BUT, I DON'T THINK THAT
RACISM IS OKAY.
AND LIBERALS DO.
AND I JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR
AND I WANT OUR VIEWERS TO
UNDERSTAND THAT IS THE
OFFICIAL POSITION OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS THAT
HURTING PEOPLE ON THE BASIS
OF THEIR RACE IS A-OKAY?
>> NO.
THE POSITION OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTIES IS THAT
WE HAVE TO TAKE COGNIZANCE
OF THE FACT THAT WHAT
HAPPENED FOR 200 YEARS AND
IF WE ACT LIKE IT DIDN'T
HAPPEN, AND THAT SOMEHOW OR
ANOTHER.
>> Tucker: I'M NOT
SUGGESTING THAT NO.
>> ACT LIKE SKIN COLOR
DOESN'T MATTER.
THAT SIGNATURE NORIEGA THE
OBVIOUS.
>> Tucker: THE CHINESE KID
WHO ARRIVED HERE 20 MINUTES
AGO.
>> RIGHT.
>> Tucker: SUFFERS FROM THAT
BECAUSE OF HIS RACE.
>> NO.
>> THAT'S OKAY, THE
DEMOCRATS.
>> NO.
>> Tucker: SAME ONES US
LECTURES ANTIRACISM